this morning we're looking at how to
cope with stress in a healthy way as we
head into the third year of living with
this pandemic one survey found 32
percent of adults say they are sometimes
so stressed out by the pandemic they
struggle to make basic decisions like
what to wear or what to eat that's
according to the american psychological
association nedra glover tuab is a
licensed therapist and a new york times
best-selling author good morning how are
you doing
good morning
thanks for joining us so you know we
when we talk about stress uh you said
that you have seen pandemic related
stress increase why is that
we have been in a constant state of up
and down fluctuations and we can't get
used to what ha what's happening right
now because we know what the world used
to be like
now what are some easy tips if someone
is feeling stressed out that they can
keep with them on a daily basis
it's important to remember that we
cannot be our own selves so many of us
are trying to operate in the way that we
used to and we just can't do that
anymore it's also important to get back
to a lot of the things that we started
doing in the beginning of the pandemic
like making time for ourselves making
ways to connect
nandra how do you know when you're
having a bad day or a series of bad days
or you just or it's time really for you
to seek professional help
when we can't manage things on our own
sometimes depression is not just feeling
sad it's also feeling blah sometimes
anxiety
is not feeling like
you can do things anything we often
think that we have to be paralyzed but
it can be indecisiveness it can also be
our lack of desire to do things that we
previously enjoyed
you say it's really important to reach
out to people during this time
i'm finding a lot of people don't want
you to reach out to them but if you do
what is there something that you should
say do you have a script do you have
some guidelines on what we should do and
what we should not do
honestly honesty is key saying things
like i'm really struggling right now
people can understand it because they're
in it with you therapists have been in
the pandemic with their clients and so
when someone says
i am struggling we can tap into the part
of our sales that are also struggling
nedra your book is called set boundaries
find peace what is it about boundaries
that are so important to helping people
get to a good head space
boundaries help you create the life that
you want it helps you live your life on
your terms in a way that is pleasing for
you
now you talk about breathing and you
know i find this fascinating because
when someone has kids and they have a
little bit of a temper tantrum we say
breathe
breathe breathe but when we're stressed
out and we're having a bad day we can't
look in the mirror and tell ourselves to
breathe why is being intentional with
your breathing important
well when your kid is having a tantrum
it's important for you to breathe and
for the kia to breathe
this is true we all need to be breathing
through those tantrums but typically
when we're breathing we're just doing it
in a very routine way i've been
surprised when i actually meditate with
people they will report oh my gosh i
felt dizzy i felt like i was not in my
body and it's because we're typically
just taking breaths we're not actually
deep breathing that is a different
process and our brain and our body
responds to it in a different way
so we heard your advice do you have any
products you recommend
to help any
you know i think our phones is our go-to
device if we could just write notes to
ourselves affirm ourselves in our note
app maybe journaling using our phone
even using the voice memos we can write
letters to ourselves there are so many
things
we can do with the devices that we
already have
all right you're doing this
dear nate good job nate all done well
done today tony don't forget to breathe
uh
nedra glover tawab thank you very much
thank you for cutting through the noise